- Welcome everybody.
Thank you for coming on
this nicest day of the year
so far I think.
Our Schulman lecturer for today
is professor Ian Phillips.
Ian has taught in the Philosophy
Departments at Oxford,
where I think he got his
undergraduate degree,
at University College London,
where I believe he got his PhD,
in the University of Birmingham
and he's also taught in the
cognitive science program
at Princeton.
For the last several years,
he has been the Bloomberg
Distinguished Professor
at Johns Hopkins University.
And this is not just a fancy title,
but it's actually sort of a
new, exciting kind of thing.
Bloomberg professors must
be fully cross appointed
in multiple departments.
And so Ian is a professor of philosophy
and also a professor of
psychological and brain sciences.
Ian is one of our fields leading
philosophers of perception.
He works on many, many different topics
with a special focus on
the perception of time,
visual adaptation, blindsight,
object representations,
many different aspects of visual awareness
and the lack thereof.
And he also does some
intriguing secret work
on silences and shadows,
but that work is classified.
He's won all sorts of
prizes for this work.
His work has been selected for
the Philosopher's Annual which selects
the 10 best philosophy papers each year.
He's won a Philip Leverhulme Prize.
And I think he actually
specializes in academic awards,
which have many, many syllables.
He has won the William James Prize
for Contributions to the
Scientific Study of Consciousness
from the Association
for the Scientific Study
of Consciousness.
- [Man] Who else.
- And last year he won
the Phi Beta Kappa Society
and American Philosophical Association
Lebowitz Prize for
Philosophical Achievement
and Contributions.
This last one was
co-awarded with Ned Block.
And I think usually when
prizes in our fields
are co-awarded that means that
a committee couldn't make up
their mind or maybe it was a team.
But as far as I can tell,
you got that prize with Ned
for just arguing with him
in print about everything
and really improving
our field in the process.
Ian is a model not just
of how to make substantive
philosophical contributions,
but how to have a dispute in our field
in a like super productive,
award-winning way.
In closing, I wanna suggest that Ian
is justifiably renowned in all these ways,
not just for his
substantive contributions,
but for the way that
he's doing the philosophy
of perception, which is pretty exciting.
This Schulman Series is
about the intersection
between the sciences and the humanities.
And of course there's been
quite a lot of such interaction
generally between
philosophy and psychology.
But I think there is a sort
of dark secret in that,
which is that there's still
quite an asymmetry in one way,
which is that increasingly
today there are,
I think a great many philosophers
who are paying close,
careful attention to what's going on
in the psychological literature
but there are really
far fewer psychologists
who are paying close, careful attention
to what's going on in the
philosophical literature.
And Ian really breaks this mold.
His work is of course, very
well sighted in philosophy,
which is not so unusual
but what's more special is that his work
is increasingly making a
real difference in racking
up all sorts of citations in
psychology and neuroscience.
And it's really because
he's doing this work
in a different way, as a vision scientist,
it's sort of easy to have
a love, hate relationship
with the philosophy of perception.
And that's in part because so
much philosophy of perception
has been done by people who know about
the Muller-Lyer illusion
and that gorilla experiment.
And that's basically all it takes.
In fact, one of those, you
could write a book on it
as far as I can tell,
but Ian in stark contrast has
been really paying attention
to the nitty gritty of all of this work.
I'm pretty sure he knows
parts of our field better
than those of us who we're actually
in the trenches doing this work.
And most importantly, he's
doing philosophical work,
which shows how those
details can really matter
as I think we'll hear about today,
please welcome Ian Phillips.
(audience applauding)
- Okay, thank you so much Brian
for that incredibly kind introduction.
It's over honor to be here.
Thank you for coming in
this gorgeous weather.
So today I want to begin with a passage
from the philosopher, Andy Clark,
in which he gives voice to
what he takes to be naive
or intuitive, though in
Clark's view completely
false vision of how our
mental lives unfold.
So this is what Clark says.
"Our human mental life looks to involve
a seamless unfolding of
perception, action, and experience,
a golden braid in which
each element twines
intimately with the rest.
We see the very world we act in
and we act in the very world we see,
but more than this visual
experience presents us
with the world in a
way apt for the control
and find guidance of action."
So I think there are a
kind of three core ideas
here in the Clark.
The first is just the all perception
is conscious perception, okay?
That being the most intimate entwining
of perception and experience, so to see,
or to hear and so forth, is just
to perceptually experience the world.
Sand the second thought
is that if you like
all worldly action guidance is perceptual.
So insofar as the world informs you
as an agent in the course
of engaging in some action,
it informs us exclusively
through perceptual channels.
And the final thought
is something like this,
that all perception is
available for action guidance.
So that's a kind of
minimal access condition
if you like on perceptual experience.
Okay, so we see the world we act in,
we act in the world we see.
Now anyone who's at all familiar with
the cognitive science of the
last 50 years will know that
it has uncovered what
many regard as repeated
and decisive counter
examples to these ideas.
Okay, so grounds for unbraiding this braid
in particular working
cognitive neuropsychology
has witnessed apparently
striking dissociation
of action and awareness and
conditions like blindsight,
unilateral neglect and visual form agnosia
and psychophysical work
with neurotypical subjects
has uncovered extensive evidence
of visual processing in
the absence of awareness.
So most notably studies
of subliminal priming,
and also in the domain of
visually guided action.
And over the last several years,
I've pressed really a dilemma against
the idea that perception and
consciousness dissociate,
which really divides
over a simple question.
So take any case where
you've allegedly got
some coming apart of perception
experience or action,
how did you measure whether experience
was really there or not?
How did you establish
the absence of awareness?
So there are two broad categories
of things you might do.
You might use so-called
subjective measures,
or you might use objective measures.
So let's take the first horn.
So if you were use so-called
subjective measures
to assess awareness, we
just simply asked subjects,
did you see anything or not?
Or were you conscious of anything or not?
Then a notorious concern arises
and it's often called the
problem with the criterion.
It goes back to early
signal detection theorists
and as it manifests in
this particular context,
it's just the concern that
subjects might underestimate
their conscious experience.
And so what I wanna do
now in the first sort
of substantial chunk of
the talk is illustrate
that concern with respect
to a particular case,
namely the case of blindsight
that Brian mentioned.
Okay, so back in the 70s, researchers
most notably Larry Weiskrantz
at Oxford began extensive
investigation of a really
astonishing condition,
which remains the most discussed
neuropsychological case
in both the contemporary science
and philosophy of consciousness.
And this is work if you're interested,
that's wonderfully summarized
in the third edition
of this landmark book
"Blindsight" by Weiskrantz.
As I'm sure many of you know,
blindsight is a condition
caused by destruction
of an are of the brain
called primary visual cortex
it's now at the back of the brain,
which is kind of the first port of call
or the first cortical port
of call of visual signals
from the eyes and here
you can see two scans
of two patients, the most extensively
investigated patient GY,
who as a child had a road
traffic accident leading
to a lesion of almost sort of
of V1 primary visual cortex
in his left hemisphere here,
and then a fascinating, but
much less explored patient TN
who had the misfortune
of having two strokes,
roughly 30 days apart.
And so lost actually more than
just primary visual cortex,
but primary visual
cortex on first one side
and then the other side of his brain.
So he has bilateral blindsight.
Okay, and because of the organization
of the primary visual system,
the damage to a region of V1 leads to
so called contra-lateral,
opposites side field deficits.
So patient GY here with a left lesion
has severe deficits with
perception on the right.
So given that damage,
it's not that surprising
you might think that
subjects with blindsight
with this such lesions say they're blind
in the corresponding areas.
So if you ask GY, as he
is asked in an interview,
what happened to him, he just says,
well, I've lost all
the vision to my right.
And in the clinic that's confirmed
by what's called
perimetry, probably an exam
that many of you have had yourselves
where the clinician just
presents in this case,
bright, high contrast white
stimuli at various locations
in that blind right visual field.
And what you're seeing
here in this kind of plot,
these white circles along
the vertical meridian
and at the center here, are
case is where GY has said yes,
by a button press.
I saw the high contrast stimulus,
but these black radio
cases where he said no.
So it looks to all purposes
that he's just blind
in the vast majority of
his right visual field.
But of course that's not the whole story.
There's a huge amount of work on patients
like GY establishing that there's actually
quite extensive visual function
that remains after this damage.
So does evidence of his capacity
to discriminate motion in particular left,
right or horizontal vertical motion
with another patient the studies that show
he's able to discriminate
the orientation of a line
or an X from an O,
his work on effective
blindsight showing that GY
can distinguish between a happy
and sad emotionally expressed emotions,
a facially expressed expressed emotions.
And again, with GY that he can detect
simple high contrast
stimuli in his blind field.
So I mentioned before patient TN,
and this is perhaps the
most dramatic example
of preserve visual function.
So remember TN has complete
bilateral blindsight.
So denies being able to see anything
in a perimetry exam, but this is
a video of him walking down a corridor
and that's Weiskrantz
closely shadowing him behind.
And as you'll see, he's able to navigate
these kind of bits of office paraphernalia
that have been put in his
path pretty effectively,
despite saying, I have
no idea how I did this.
I'm completely blind.
And this kind of performance has led many
to question kind what's the
point of being conscious
if you can get around the world like this
without being conscious,
then why are we conscious?
Okay, so whatever exactly you think
an extremely common view is
that blindside is revolutionary.
So here's Weiskrantz in retrospect
describing how back in the 70s,
which is immediately obvious
to him and his colleagues
that the phenomenon of
successful performance
without awareness across a
startling new broad range
of visual tasks just must have a bearing
on the neural and philosophical
aspects of consciousness
and here's a philosopher Paul
Churchland, actually writing
in the context of Weiskrantz's work of how
the revolutionary blindsight result
just knocked the stuffing
out of the obvious assumption
that awareness of a signal is necessary
for an intentional
response to that signal.
And that's just part of
the golden braid conception
that we need to be aware of things
if we're going to act in
response to them in the world.
So, first question, does blindsight show
that the golden braid is mistaken?
Well, in fact, there's a simple
and powerful alternative way
of thinking about blindsight,
but one I think that's
been unjustly neglected.
And so to approach this
kind of alternative picture,
notice first that the
tasks used to establish
the absence of awareness in blindsight
are subjective measures.
So in the perimetry
exam I mentioned before
GY's just being asked, you know,
did you see anything or not
following the presentation of a stimulus?
And that kind of question is subject
to what is known as
conservative response bias.
So let me just illustrate that
and I want you to think of yourself
as a blindsight patient like GY,
and so you have by any objective measure,
extremely degraded vision in
your right hand visual field.
Okay, so you have pretty normal vision
on your left hand field.
That's how you get around
the world normally,
but your right hand field,
you don't see colors,
you don't really see visual form at all.
You don't really see all
objects in any real sense.
Maybe you just have a sense somehow
I mean, I'm not saying this
it's conscious at this point,
but just the objective
measures are, you know,
of you being able to detect
extremely high contrast
or extremely kind of salient stimuli only.
So the experiment to ask you after
the presentation is some stimulus,
did you see anything on that trial?
And what are you supposed
to make of that question?
You might think maybe this is sort
of somewhat philosophical kind of question
and philosophers do
not agree on the answer
to this question.
What does it take to see something?
What does it mean to see something?
I mean, that's just
being handed over to me
to make a decision about that.
How sure do I have to be that
what has just happened to me
counts as a case of seeing?
How sure do I have to be that there
was a stimulus there to say yes and so on?
Maybe you think something like this,
well, the experience
I had was just nothing
like seeing something
in my I sighted field,
so quotes, normal seeing.
So I should probably say no.
Or you might think, well,
I had some really vague awareness,
but I wouldn't say I
saw anything specific.
So I guess I'll say no.
Or you might think I'm not sure whether
I saw something or not.
So I maybe I'll play it safe
and I'll say no.
Okay, so for all of those
reasons, and may the others,
you might think a negative
response in an exam
like this needn't be taken as a guarantee
that there was absolutely no awareness
because there's this other factor, namely,
all that decisional
thinking that goes on after
your experience that we
need to take into account.
Okay, so that's the tasks that
I used to assess awareness.
What about the tasks that I used
to assess residual visual capacity?
Well, these are typically
so-called forced choice
or maybe forced response tasks.
And these are effectively, at
least the forced choice tasks
effectively bias free.
So let me say what I mean by that.
So in a forced choice
task you're presented
with in a two alternative case,
two temporal spatial intervals.
So there's gonna be a stimulus
in just one of those two
intervals and you have to choose which.
And so here, I mean I have no idea
how these slides appear to you
and whether it's completely obvious to you
that there's a patch in
one and not in the other,
but suppose they were in
presented to you on their own.
And you might think,
I don't think I can see
anything in either of those.
So each interval presented
on its own is one
such that you would say,
no, I don't see anything,
but you don't have that
option here of saying,
no, there's nothing there,
or I don't see anything.
You have to choose which of
these, the stimulus is in.
And you know there is a
stimulus in one of them.
So what do you do when you naturally pick
whichever interval it
is that's most likely
to contain a stimulus.
Perhaps you might think
that which just gave
you that dimmest flicker
or hint of awareness
of there being something there.
Okay, so you might think
that, but you have to choose.
So you think maybe there
was something faint
in the first and you go for that.
So I hope it's clear, even
from this brief presentation
that these forced choice tasks are kind
of a great tool for a psycho physicist
to ascertain a subject
sensitivity independent
of their bias, because bias
doesn't really factor into this,
unless you have a particular preference
for interval ones over interval twos
there's no question of
conservative criterion coming in.
Okay, so that kind of framework sets up
the thought that actually all
the data concerning blindsight
is consistent with a picture on which
what the brain damage
has done is to severely
and maybe qualitatively degrade
the subject's vision in their blind field,
perhaps to the point
where it's just too weak
or degraded or qualitatively
different to count to them
as seeing, as I say,
there's no color, no form,
no objects and so on.
But nonetheless, there is
a conscious signal there,
which is sufficient to
perform above chance
when you force the
subject to make a decision
between two alternatives.
So I can't give a full defense
of that viewpoint here,
but I just want to give you three sort of,
almost tantalizing teaser bits of evidence
that make me think this
hypothesis is on the right lines.
So one important thing to notice
is that blindsight patients
do report awareness,
especially when the question
is changed subtly and what you think,
what I think maybe the question changes
about is the question
change elicits a different,
more liberal criterion in the subject.
So they're more prepared to say yes
to this question than the others.
So here I mentioned slight misleadingly
that this was the perimetry
plot from this paper,
and it is the classic perimetry plot
in all the early papers on blindsight.
That's, you know, the kind
of plot you see for GY,
but these experimentalists also asked
a different question with
just the same stimuli
in a second block.
So that different question was just press
when you're aware of something.
So we had press when you see something,
nothing, press when
you're aware of something
and suddenly you get all
these positive responses.
Okay, so there's clearly
some kind of awareness
in much of the visual field
if you trust these answers.
Second kind of bit of evidence,
usually blindsight patients
in these experiments
are given a binary choice
between yes and no responses.
They can either say yes, I saw
it, or no, I didn't see it.
But what happens when we
give a blindsight subject
a more fine grain response scale?
So this is a study done
by Mazzi and colleagues
with a different patient,
a woman called SL.
And what they did was
just give her a bunch
of different discrimination
tasks, like orientation color,
and so on discrimination tasks.
And after every trial asked her,
did you do that task
by seeing the stimulus
or were you just guessing?
So a standard yes, no measure.
And what they found was that in,
the black bars indicate,
I was just guessing.
So no responses, that only
in one of the cases here
did she acknowledge that
she was seeing anything
and that that was driving her responses.
But then again, they did exactly
the same discrimination
tasks, but affording her
the luxury of being able to
respond in four different ways.
So she could say I had no
experience, I had weak experience,
I had almost clear experience,
or I had clear experience,
and this is what happened.
It turned out that the black bars,
which are indicating guess responses,
so, no, I didn't have any
experiences, actually look
like they comprised
zero, so no experience,
but also this dark gray,
I had weak experience.
And similarly the yes, I saw something,
corresponds here to
almost clear experience.
So it looks like what the
subject has been doing
with the yes, no is using
no to mean none or weak
and the yes, to mean
clear or almost clear.
And it's a little hard
to tell too much from
this particular study
because the performance
is quite low across the board,
but there was no evidence
of above chance performance,
just looking at the
cases where no experience
at all was reported that had to at least
be weak experience before
reported before or one
got any performance.
Okay, final bit of teaser evidence.
This is from a study by
Zeki and FFytche of GY.
And they gave him a whole
bunch of different kind
of conditions and in particular,
in one particular very
low contrast condition,
he just spontaneously responds.
I mean, he knows his
experimenters very well,
you know, hey, my awareness
score in this particular block
should be quotes minus one or minus two.
And I think what that really tells you
is that his zero was not absolute zero
if he's prepared to give minus
one or minus two responses.
Okay so in general, I hope
that gives you some sense
(audience laughing)
that the judgments of
awareness are one should
be suspicious about and
it turns out that they,
there is awareness
there if you really find
the right way to at it.
And I think there's a case to
be made that that correlates
quite well with performance also.
But if you want a really
systematic and sustained defense
of that view against lots of
psychophysical objections,
then let me advertise this paper.
Okay, whatever one thinks of blindsight,
the residual vision is
really very limited.
So, you know, there
are sometimes anecdotes
about how a blindsighted
patient wouldn't reach out
for a glass of water if they were thirsty,
well that's 'cause they can't see objects.
I mean there's no vision capable
of anything like that kind of richness.
But in the 80s research is interested
in a rather different condition
reported evidence of as they put it
unconscious perception analysis
far more extensive than a dreamt of
in most current theories.
And the most current
theories were precisely
this theories that were being
motivated by blindsight.
So this is evidence from
a condition called neglect
and neglect is a really complicated
and kind of fractionated disorder,
it's associated to much later damage
in the visual hierarchy.
So typically it follows a stroke
and it's associated with damage to
kind of right inferior parietal
and temporal parietal regions.
And it's characterized
by a failure to respond,
or report, or attend to, or
orient to significant stimuli
on the other side of space
where that's not due to, you know,
you not being able to see
in some elementary senses,
no damage to your eyes or
very early visual areas
nor to being able to respond
in the kind of other end
of things in a motorway.
And you often see these kinds
of pictures in textbooks.
So this is a picture of a house
and the patient has just
been asked to copy it
and you can see they've
just failed to copy out
the left hand side,
here they've been asked to bisect a line
and you can see that
they've bisected it too far
to the right as if they're
ignoring this part of the line.
And this classic line cancellation task
is a case where the
patient just in free vision
has been asked to strike through
all the lines they can see.
And they've not done that with
the ones on the left at all,
but they've repeatedly done
it with the ones on the right.
Okay, and so here's a
really classic study,
really a case report rather than a study,
that it was the beginning of
a much more extensive body
of work but I just wanna
talk about the simple study,
partly 'cause it's the one
that's always cited still
and you know, widely
discussed even to this day,
I just read Hackman Lao's
new book on consciousness,
which is a really interesting book.
And it talks about this
study and it suffices,
I think to make the basic
point about a lot of the work.
So here a patient called
PS with severe neglect
was shown these two houses just on cards
and asked the following questions.
Are these houses the same or different?
As she says they're the same.
Is there anything wrong with either card?
Nope.
Okay, but which house would
you prefer to live in?
And understandably she says,
that's a silly question,
but when forced to make a response,
she chooses there's none burning one
on nine of the 11 trials.
Kind of that's why it's not a study,
but just the nine of the 11 trials.
But you know, this is someone who's
just had a stroke probably.
Okay what the, do the authors say,
well, they say that these
preference judgments
clearly indicate covert knowledge
without conscious perceptual awareness,
showing unconscious perception
analysis far more extensive,
as I said than is dreamt
of in our current theories
and so what are they thinking,
well they're presumably thinking
that she's seeing these flames,
you can see this as
house is a burning house.
That's what's driving
her preference judgment,
but that can't be
conscious 'cause otherwise
she would've said they were different
or something was wrong
with the two houses.
The problem here again though,
is that these questions are very,
very different questions
to be asking someone.
If you ask a question are two
things the same or different,
you need yourself to make up your mind
like, well how different do two things
have to be before I
count them is different.
You know, how much difference
do there have to be?
Similarly if you're asked the question,
is there anything wrong with either card,
you have to make up your mind,
well, how much has to be wrong before
I say something is wrong?
What is it to be?
What is it for something
to be wrong with something?
Okay, so these are questions
that are both biased
in the sense that subjects show
a tendency to say the same,
even when there are visible
differences between stimuli.
So that's would be a kind
of way of being conservative
towards making different judgments.
And again, you might expect
people to be conservative
in saying something was wrong because
they might be hesitant to do that.
In contrast, this is a slightly unusual,
but it's a forced choice question.
You have to pick one of these two houses.
So you don't have the
option of saying, well,
I don't really care.
I mean, she does say that,
but then she's forced to guess.
So once we see that the
pattern of responses here
and in future experiments
is just fully consistent
with a picture on which
what neglect has led to
is some kind of degraded
conscious awareness
of the left hand side of this object
or the left hand side of space.
Maybe just something being a
bit off with one of the houses
or something being
slightly smudgy over there
or an asymmetry in the stimulus.
And that's not sufficient
to drive a different
or yes response, but it is to bias her,
to lead her to make this
preference judgment.
So I mean, maybe it's a bit like this.
I don't know whether you can see anything
in the left hand side of space there,
but that's just this
kind of slight smudging.
Okay, so let's go back to our dilemma.
So that's subjective
measures and how they crop up
into kind of critical cases
but what if we adopt a more
rigorous objective test
of awareness and insists that a stimulus
just has to be completely undetectable
of to count as unconscious
that would rule out blindsight and neglect
as cases of unconscious perception
or at least clear cases of such,
but it would also overcome this
problem with the criterion.
Okay, so if we do that,
then I think a different issue arises.
And the key point here is
if the subject cannot detect
the stimulus, we need
some other way of showing
that they've seen it.
And a standard way of doing that would be
to do a priming study and
show some priming effects.
So we might present the
subject with this arrow here,
mask it shortly afterwards
and in such a way
that perhaps the prime is undetectable
and then follow it up with a
consciously perceived target
to which we ask the subject
to respond in some way.
So maybe they just press left or right
and it turns out that
their right responses
are marginally faster when
a congruent right prime
has been proceeded, has proceeded them.
Okay, let's assume we do get such effects.
The issue though here is that
the priming effect itself
can be understood simply in terms
of the automatic activation of
some subsystem of the individual.
So maybe their visual system
or maybe their visual motor
system can think of
this primers, you know,
activating representations
in your early visual areas
that since activated
will lead to this target
being perceived slightly
faster if they're congruent
as opposed to incongruent
or maybe the motor response
has been activated.
And so you're slightly
faster to fire it off
when you see this target.
But perception isn't a state
of your primary visual cortex
or of your supplementary motor area
or any of these parts of your brain nor
even of a cognitive subsystem of yours.
It's a state that you are
in, you are the perceiver,
you perceive things.
So we can't just conclude from an effect
that shows an effect on a sub system
that you yourself have
perceived something.
So I call this a problem of attribution
and you know, it's like,
I think an extremely difficult question
as to how we should solve this problem.
Like what are the marks
of the individual level?
But I kind of widely agreed mark,
and I say mark advisedly because
know many people would say
it wasn't necessary or sufficient,
but just a good guide
of the individual level
is if a state or an
episode or representation
is directly available to guide action.
So if a subject can
use that representation
to make some choice or
to guide their action
in some purpose of way,
then we should think
of it as an individual
level representation.
And these primes aren't
available to do that.
So the action is guided
by this target here.
These simply modulate the
way you end up responding
to this in some modest way.
But as a result of this kind
of dilemma in the setup,
a lot of the debate and
Brian mentioned Ned.
So, you know, here are
some of the many things
I've written in debate with Ned
about these issues has
really come to focus
on this issue of
unconscious action guidance.
So the reason for that
is that if we could find
compelling evidence of
unconscious action guidance,
that gets around the
problem of attribution
and so does provide a case of kind of
a clear counter example
to the golden braid.
And these are some other
papers which again,
by Josh Shepard and Myrto
Mylopoulos and Jake Berger,
which again, kind of
press the same thought.
So in the last part of the talk,
I want to talk about a
couple of these cases.
Okay, so in the background here is
a canonical framework for thinking
about visual and motor
action due to Mel Goodale
And David Milner here,
called the so-called
two visual system hypothesis
and very, very roughly the hypothesis says
that when visual signal goes
on from primary visual cortex,
it proceeds into anatomically
and functionally separate streams.
Okay, the first pathway,
which is a kind of eventual pathway here
Milner and Goodale dubbed
vision for perception,
since in their view, it is
responsible for the construction
of conscious representations
of our environments,
representation which
gets thought in memory
and are then used for, you
know, making judgments,
recognizing, categorizing,
and also thinking about the world
and planning future actions
and a second pathway here
that Milner and Goodale
called vision for action
and which is claimed to be responsible
for the online control of
our visually guided actions.
So reaching and grasping and so on,
and a critical part of
this framework has it
that the information in this dorsal stream
is completely unconscious, okay?
In principle cannot be
accessed consciously.
There's been hugely
influential in philosophy.
I won't read out these quotations,
but here's Andy Clark,
the context of his rejection
of the golden braid
is precisely this,
insisting that the involvement
of this dorsal information
in our online action control
is just completely immense
and pervasive.
Again raising a question about why we need
to be conscious at all.
Here's Brogaard saying
something very similar arguing
that actually we're never
really consciously aware
of exactly what we're doing
because all of what
we're doing at a moment
is being guided by the dorsal stream.
That's not to say there's not
been push back in philosophy.
So they're very nice paper by
Josh Shwenkler and Rob Briscoe
from a few years ago saying that
there's the two visual
assistant hypothesis too crude.
That there's plenty of evidence
that the spatial contents
of visual experience are
eventual stream representations
are in fact involved in
online motor guidance
and programming.
But even they are not
interested in objecting
to the idea that there's just
masses of empirical evidence,
that there are unconscious
sources of information
that do significantly
influence our bodily actions.
Okay, so why think that the
dorsal stream representation
is unconscious?
I think there are two basic reasons.
And so here's Josh Shepherd
and Myrto Mylopoulos
asking and answering that
question citing these two sources.
They say the first source
of evidence involves
visual and motor appointing tasks.
And the second involves this
case of visual form agnosia
in particular patient DF.
So let me just talk about those.
This is actually really old body of work.
One of the luxuries being
philosopher is that you can,
you know, site work from 50
years ago and that's okay.
But I think it's really
important to go back
to the foundations of these things
and reassess them sometimes.
So this is work that goes back to,
to Bruce Bridgeman in the early 80s,
I guess it kind of came to its full,
flourishing with Mark Jeannerod here.
Mel Goodale did a bunch of this work.
There's a huge research program here,
and it's still widely
appealed to by philosophers,
but here are two classic tasks.
So in this task from Goodale,
Pelisso, Prablanc from 86,
you, the subject will be
sat in front of a target
and your task is to wait for that target
to jump to your right and
then to reach out immediately
and point to it.
So the target's gonna
jump, you point to it.
In 50% of the trials though, the target
is gonna jump an extra 10%.
You're not told about this,
but this is just the case.
So it's gonna jump an extra
three to five centimeters
just as you're saccading,
just as you're moving
your eyes to that target.
So under these conditions,
subjects never notice that
there is any extra jump
it's time to coincide
with their eye movements.
So it's kind of hidden, but nonetheless,
they adjust their
trajectory as if the target
had basically immediately
gone to that location.
So there's just no difference
in the trajectories
of the jump targets,
as opposed to one that
was sent there originally.
And on that basis, Goodale
and colleagues say, look,
this is just a clear demonstration that
the neural mechanisms
mediating the perception
of target position can be dissociated from
those mediating visually
guided reaching movements,
a dissociation reminiscent of the behavior
of cortically blind patients.
It's actually repeated,
refrain in this literature
that blindsight is set up
something that constantly
gets referred back to.
Okay, here's a second experiment,
very similar by Castiello and colleagues
from Mark Jeannerod's lab.
You as a subject again, sat
in front of some targets
this time there are
these translucent dowels
which can be illuminated
and your task initially
is just to wait for
the dowel to light up and
then reach out towards it.
And also to make the sound
tah, just to say, tah out loud,
just a meaningless vocalization,
But in the critical session,
trials all began with the
second dowel being illuminated.
But then in the minority
in 20% of the trials,
the light would jump to
the left or to the right.
Subjects were told this would happen.
And in these pertubated trials,
they were instructed to
just track the shift.
So instead of going to the
middle one, now go left or right,
And then say tah again, to indicate that
they'd consciously
experience the visual change
that had taken place.
Okay, so second one goes
on, you say tah immediately,
then it jumps and then you say tah again
and reach out to it.
Looking at the motor correction
that occurs in this study,
the experimentalist established
that the reaction time,
the time it takes between
the jump happening
and the hand trajectory changing is
about a hundred milliseconds,
but the vocal reaction
time was much longer,
nearly 420 milliseconds on average.
So it took nearly, you know,
oh, well over 300 milliseconds for sub,
between the change in
the movement and the vocalization to come.
And indeed on some occasions they report
the dissociation was so striking
that to their own surprise, subjects
were already lifting
the first or third dowel
by the time they were
emitting that vocal response.
So what does this show?
Well, the thought is
that's given in the paper
is that this extra 300
milliseconds is the time required
for conscious percept
experience to be generated,
but you don't need
conscious percept experience
to guide your actions as a
guided by this other system,
that what later becomes identified
as this vision for action pathway.
So again, where these
results are said to show
a clear dissociation
between motor responses
and awareness like blindsight,
and you know, this is from
a textbook this picture,
and that's what the textbook tells you.
It's possible to disassociate behavior
and conscious awareness.
But I think there's a
much simpler explanation
of what's going on in these tasks.
And to see this, just
reflect that in order
to accurately point or
reach out towards a target,
you only have to represent
its current location.
You don't care where it
was or where it will be.
You just need to know where
it is now in the moment,
but that does not suffice
for you to detect a change,
to detect a change you
need to do a whole bunch
of other things, especially if that change
has been hidden from you by
occurring during a saccade.
You need to encode the original
location of the target.
You need to maintain that representation,
you need to retrieve it when
the new occasion comes around
and you need to compare
those two representations.
So there's a whole sequence
of steps that need take place
if you're going to accurately
judge there's been a change.
Okay, and so to kind of
give you a sense of that,
and if you've seen this
before, I apologize,
but I just want you to
indulge me by staring
at the next slide for 30 seconds
and see if you spot anything unusual.
Okay, so maybe I've spot
it by just saying that,
but this was the final slide you saw.
And I dunno whether any of you realized
who hadn't seen it before, but
this was the original slide.
Okay, so massive change in color.
If you're anything like me,
you did not notice when
you first saw this, okay.
But the last thing that you
want to conclude from this
is that we don't see colors, okay?
What this shows you
presumably is that you can
accurately represent the color
of something at any particular moment,
even though you fail across
time to do that whole procedure
of maintaining, retrieving
and comparing accurately.
Okay, so this is just a class example
of change blindness and
the point to be made
about change blindness is
that the failures notice
to the change doesn't in
itself mean you didn't see
the particular feature
that changed at the moment
before or after the change.
And I really think the same
thing is going on here.
The failure to notice an extra jump
in the target doesn't mean that
you don't consciously
perceive the target position
effectively throughout the experiment.
So there's not a clear demonstration here
of a dissociation between
mechanisms mediating
the perception of target
position and those mediating
the visually guided reaching movements.
Both might be accurate representations
of the current target position,
what there's been a
failure of as a failure
to detect a change, but
that wasn't necessary to do
the reaching task
and nor is it necessary to
see the accurate position
of the target consciously.
And the same I think is true here.
The course correction reflects
that you you've accurately
updated the, your
representation of the target's
current location, like where
the light currently is.
But remember tah was
meant to be the signal
of your conscious experience
of a visual change.
So have you detected and are you,
do you feel able to judge
that a change has occurred
and you might then think
that that detection process
requires some extra time go through some
of those processing steps,
the retrieval, the comparison and so on,
and that's what's explaining the delay
not the time needed for
conscious experience.
So again, I don't think there's evidence
for dissociation here.
Okay, let me now just finally talk about
the second set of evidence.
So and again this is
gonna be extremely brief
and extremely narrow,
but I'm more than happy
to talk about other cases in the Q and A.
So patient DF who has
this condition called
visual form agnosia
suffered very badly actually
from carbon monoxide poisoning
and had sort of extensive
lesions, but in particular,
she has extensive lesions on both sides
to her ventral stream.
So remember the stream
that Milner and Goodale
called vision for perception,
that's associated with these
conscious representations
of her vision environment.
And she's not blind because
V1 was largely spared
and she can see color, she can see texture
but she has real problems
with object recognition.
She struggles to see size,
shape, orientation, and so forth.
And just to give you some sense of that is
an imaging study in which
she and here controls
are shown these line drawings
and the activity elicited
in these ventral pathways
when presented with these line drawings
is compared to the
scrambled versions here.
And so in the control subjects,
you can see there's extensive
differential activity
in presence of this bed and this pepper
compared to the scrambling, but in DF,
there's absolutely no
differential activity to be seen.
And yet despite that, she appears
to have really quite impressive abilities
for visually guided action.
So let me just talk
about one particular case
of that very famous experiment done
by Milner and Goodale
back in the 90s, early 90s
where DF was just asked to
look at this orientable slot
and do one of two things,
either to hold a card
and add a distance match
the orientation of the slot
with the card, or reach out
and post it through the slot.
Okay, and I'll show you a video
of her doing this in a sec,
but here's the pattern of data.
She's incredibly bad
at this matching task.
These are kind of
normalized to the vertical,
but you can see that her
performance there is almost random,
whereas in the vision motor posting task,
she's not perfect or not
exactly like control subjects,
but incredibly close.
So this is the standard
story that's then told
about this pattern of data.
And here's, this is a
quotation from Ned Block.
DF is almost as good as
posting as our normal controls,
but nearly random at matching.
What explains this, well,
her conscious mind can't see orientation.
That's why she can't do the matching task.
Nonetheless, it must be the
orientation is perceived
otherwise how could she
do the posting task?
Well, that must be perceived in
this unconscious action
guiding part of her brain.
So here is her doing the matching task.
Let me just show you one example of that
when you can already see,
this is just wait for the experimenter
to reorient the slot.
Okay, and now she's being asked to match.
Okay so, and this goes on and every time
there's really no relation
you can see between the okay, but here's
the more impressive thing, here is a case
of the slot being moved
and her being asked
to reach out and post through it.
Okay, so really a remarkable dissociation.
Problem is again, there's
an alternative explanation
of what's going on.
And the thing is that needs recognizing
is that you don't need to be
able to perceive orientation
to do the posting task.
And that's 'cause there's
another way of doing it.
You can succeed in posting by using
what's called an obstacle
avoidance strategy.
And what that involves is you seeking
to minimize the distances
between the edges
of the slot and the edges of the card,
sorry, maximize the
distances, not minimize them.
So if you can create maximum safety margin
or, you know, room between
the edges of the slot and
the edges of the card,
you will post successfully.
And in fact, you don't actually, you know,
orientation is kind of neither
necessary nor sufficient
for doing the task.
If you know the orientation,
you still can't do the task
unless you know the midpoint,
but if you don't know the orientation
and you do know like
that as held like this,
you've managed to maximize
the distances between
the card and the slot edge,
then you will be able to do the task.
So this strategy is
strictly orientation free.
Okay, but is there any evidence
this is what's actually going on?
Well, the first piece of
evidence that was proposed
for this account comes from a paper
by Hess, Franz and Schenk from 2011.
And what they do is they modify the slot
so that actually the orientation,
whether it's the maximum safety margin
is not the vertical of the
slot, but it's diagonal.
So it's a wide slot, but
they use very big cards.
And what they find this is
just neurotypical subjects,
is that the orientation era,
namely the departure from that vertical
is pretty large in about
half of the subjects
suggesting that about half of
the subjects do in fact
post through this slot with
a non, not orienting to
the slot's orientation,
but rather maximizing the safety margin.
And interestingly, there's no relation
between their matching behavior
and whether they do that
or whether they stick
to this strategy or not.
So this is some suggestive evidence,
but in response to this,
Block in particular,
but others too have
been rather unimpressed.
They say, well, this is
just very weak evidence.
This is a very weak criticism
of the original study
for three reasons.
One, look that a task that's
been deliberately designed to
elicit obstacle avoidance
does so in normal subjects,
doesn't show anything
about what DF is doing.
Second, as you saw in
the video I showed you,
DF moves our hand forward unhesitatingly
and almost always
inserts the card smoothly
into the slot, Block says,
and she also begins to
rotate the card towards
the correct orientation when
in advance of arriving at it.
And finally he says that he
thinks orientation perception
would be required to avoid hitting
the edge of the slot with the card.
Now I just think that's not
correct, although I don't,
he doesn't say any more than this.
So I don't know precisely the thinking,
but I do not think it's true
that you need orientation
to succeed in this task.
With respect to this criticism,
I think this would be
correct as a criticism
if there was somehow an
obvious difference between
the subjects who did,
who used the strategy and the Hess paper,
but actually they also, if
you look at the details,
all had adjusted the card
to that as it were diagonal
orientation by midway
through their trajectories.
And they all posted
smoothly and effortlessly
in a similar way.
So it really the key point here is that
this difference in
strategy doesn't predict
that you wouldn't be able to do a smooth
posting movement or that
you wouldn't be able to get
the orientation in advance.
It's just a difference in
the information being used.
But the first point is I
think absolutely right,
that we can't generalize too
much from this early study,
but I now think there's stronger evidence.
And this comes from the same group
from a much more recent paper.
And it exploits an effect
known as the oblique effect.
So all of us are reliably more accurate
in judging horizontal
and vertical orientations
than oblique orientations.
So, you know, cardinal
orientations are just,
if you look around the room
you'll see they're all over the place.
We're very, very used to them.
And our visual systems
are very used to them.
So we're better at discriminating
horizontals and vertical as
than oblique orientations.
So if posting were to
be based on orientation,
you'd expect it to show an oblique effect.
If it's based on an
obstacle avoidance strategy,
which is orientation-free, you wouldn't.
So just as proof of concept,
here's evidence from a matching paradigm
which does show an oblique effect.
So in both these two conditions here,
the open loop means the
subjects can't see the target
as soon as they've begun the movement.
So that's why the errors are larger.
You're seeing errors in the
matching of an orientation
and you can see they're much lower with
the horizontal and verticals
here than with the obliques.
Without posting no such effect.
Okay, there is a pattern
in this data though,
and which some of you know
that will have spotted looks like errors
are increasing in this direction.
Well that's because they
were started from a,
at the same kind of post
horizontal rotation position.
So we can fix that as
the experimentalists did
by using variable starting positions.
And we can also do one other
thing that's important.
We can introduce a delay
between the presentation
of the target and the action being made.
And that's important because
it's natural to worry
or think that maybe the two
visual systems people will say,
but maybe the dorsal stream,
maybe our action guiding
stream doesn't have
an oblique effect associated with it.
Maybe that's just a ventral stream thing,
But those people, Goodale
and Milner do think
that once you introduce
a delay are actions
fall back on ventral
stream representations.
So action guiding
representations are supposed
to be kind of on the fly, in
the moment representations
which are used in online guidance,
but when we are falling back on memory
we use the ventral stream.
So this delay ought to definitely
get us an oblique effect
if there is one to be found, of course,
here's the matching data
again, showing such an effect,
but here's the posting data
again showing no such effect.
So this is all data from
neurotypical subjects,
but what is really suggesting
is that neurotypical subjects
don't use orientation
information primarily
in guiding the posting
we're using obstacle
avoidance strategies.
Okay so in general, subjects use
orientation-free obstacle
avoidance strategies, or at least,
I mean really is evidence
to their orientation-free,
not specifically that
they're obstacle avoidance,
but in their posting.
And so our default
hypothesis now should be
that DF is doing that.
And if that's right then her performance
on the posting class
clearly doesn't establish
that she's perceived the
orientation of the slot
in an unconscious action
guiding part of her brain.
The simplest thing to say is that
she just can't see orientation.
Okay, I'm over the time that
I said I would speak for
so I'm gonna wrap up now,
but there's a huge number
of other bits of evidence
that I could have mentioned
but this is a real take home
I want to leave you with
What I've argued is that
across a very diverse range
of cases and for a whole
set of different reasons,
these apparently striking
dissociations of performance
and awareness that you have
seen in blindsight and neglect
may in fact be spacious or
artifactual in different ways.
So in the case of blindsight and neglect
it was the problem with the criterion,
which I pointed to in the
case of subliminal priming,
it's not so much the effect is suspicious
or artifact there is that
the there's a gap between
the data and what it shows
and the anything that the
golden braid is talking about,
namely perception by us and our actions.
In the case of those visual
motor action studies,
the point was that there's a conflation
or a misunderstanding
of what is being shown
by failure to detect change.
It doesn't show that we're
not tracking a feature
And in the case of visual form agnosia,
and this would apply to many other studies
of visual form agnosia, there
are just different strategies
that can be used to do different tasks.
And so when you compare two
tasks, you need to be very,
very sure that the same strategy
is being applied in both.
Okay, this then returns
us to this naive vision
I began with, which Clark paints
on which perception is always conscious
and always available for action guidance
and all action guidance occurs
with conscious perception.
And I'm not really
standing here today saying,
this is the truth.
What I am trying to stand here and say is,
this is our starting point
and we shouldn't abandon it
without extremely good evidence.
And the evidence that I've surveyed,
I don't think is decisive evidence.
So not everything that's
naive or intuitive
should be given up upon.
Okay, thank you very much for listening.
(audience applauding)
- [Lady] So thank you, Ian.
That was fantastic and we'll now open
the floor for a few questions.
- [Man] Thank you very much, Ian,
this extremely interesting paper.
In your debate with Ned Block,
I find myself wondering what you regard
as the minimal condition
would it been true that something
is conscious or aware of anything?
It seems though you and
Block had a clear idea
of what it was to be
consciously aware of something.
And you're arguing about that,
but looking at the data
one might wonder whether
first of all, awareness
isn't a matter of degree.
Secondly, whether it is vague.
And thirdly, whether there
is a determinate cutoff point
at the bottom level.
So I was wondering whether you could say
what you regarded the minimal condition
for the presence of consciousness to be.
- Yeah, thanks that, I mean,
that's a huge question with
many questions built into it.
So maybe one answer is just,
I can't give you an
answer to that question.
So I think there is a slight
difference between us and a,
but also a bit of agreement.
So I think we're both agreed the interest
is in phenomenal
consciousness, both Ned and I,
but I am inclined to impose
a kind of access condition
on that, which was an action
condition I mentioned.
So I guess I think one condition
that is a plausible condition for
a representation being
conscious is that it's,
you know, usable by the
subject in some way,
and I don't think that
the Ned would necessarily,
well, I'm pretty sure he
wouldn't agree with that.
He might be happy with the idea that there
are conscious representations that just
are completely inaccessible.
Then there's the question of degrees.
I mean, I do think so a way
in which we can make sense
of consciousness or at
least of a certain kind
of episode as being
more or less conscious,
but I also think there's that,
that's not inconsistent with
it being either true or false
that it is a conscious episode
or not, see what I mean?
So when we talk about degraded vision
or a very, very weak signal,
I think that gives us
some operational grip
on it being a conscious to
a low degree as it were,
but I still think it does a matter of fact
about whether it's conscious or not.
And then, you know,
might it be a determinant
or might it be vague?
I don't want to rule that out at all.
Nothing I've said is committed to that.
And I don't really know if that's,
there's anything in our
naive or intuitive view
which says there's always a
determinant fact of the matter,
but I mean, feel free to press me more
on things I've just said or.
- [Lady] There is one question, Mike.
- [Mike] I wanted to, I find
this all very convincing,
but I'm not familiar with
debates but still convincing,
but what do you think motivates people
like Block to insist that
performance and awareness
can be disassociated?
What's in it for them as it
were in taking this line?
Is there a philosophical motivation
or is there something that
they're not concerned with
that you are concerned with,
that can explain this difference?
- That's a really interesting question.
I don't, I mean, I feel
like I shouldn't try
and parenter Ned, so, but
I kind of think there's a,
it's particularly interesting in his case
because he has this distinction
between phenomenal and
access consciousness.
And once you've got that
distinction, you might think,
well, why not think that
many of these cases,
the cases are phenomenal
without some form of access?
So that was in ways,
the question that first got
me interested in this area,
and it's kind of a question for Ned.
So he has nonetheless though,
decided that as he sees the evidence,
it points to a kind of
tripartite distinction
between this unconscious
truly unconscious,
phenomenally conscious
and access consciousness.
I mean, I do think he's seriously guided
by the empirical evidence in this case.
And so I think that's what he would reply
and very reasonably, so many,
many people actually
with very different views
of consciousness to his,
see these cases as being,
absolutely clear demonstrations of things.
So, I mean, in ways I think there's a kind
of a really legitimate
deference to science
that's going on in a lot of philosophy,
but I think there's also
an efficient attention
to the assumptions that are going
into the interpretation of these
studies, which is what I'm,
so maybe there shouldn't have
been quite so much in my view.
- [Lady] Hi, thank you
so much for the talk.
I have to confess, I'm
very new to all of this.
So I wanted to ask a very basic question.
So it seemed that the golden
braid is tying together
three things, perception,
conscious perception,
and action guidingness.
And it seemed like the debates
over the evidence was about
whether it's conscious
perception that's action guiding,
or whether we have unconscious perception
that's action guiding.
And I wondered if you could say something
about the link between
perception and acting guidingness
in general, such that, I'm not quite sure
how to articulate it.
Can the two be pulled apart,
or is there something
about the way in which
we investigate psychologically where
it can't be pulled apart
because we're looking
at people's behaviors and as we ruled out
the subjective measures,
what happens there?
- Yeah, that's a really good question.
I mean, I think there's something
slightly terminological here.
So when Milner and Goodale
say that this visual stream
that guides action is vision for action,
they contrast it with
vision for perception.
So as the they're
talking about perception,
they're talking about
something that's conscious
or at least potentially conscious.
So then the question
is all action guidance.
Perceptual is a real one
because we're getting
this contrast between
information that's coming in,
as it were through the census,
that's genuinely
perceptual and information,
which isn't because it's going
with this dorsal pathway.
And my first move was to say,
as part of the golden braid,
all perception is conscious.
And then you can't, the
contrast that they have
can't exist at that point.
So your question then becomes
well, is there anything else,
is there any other source of information
that could be action guiding
that wasn't perceptual?
No, I actually think that
it's not totally obvious
there isn't, but it would be some kind of,
as it were extra sensory information
that in an with guiding our
actions in an online way,
and I don't know what
exactly that would be.
So, I'm not actually certain
it's in the golden braid
that, that's all ruled out,
but I don't think it's part
of our naive conception
that there are other ways
of information coming in
that aren't via the
sensors that are available
for action guidance.
Of course, there's
information that's stored
and used independently
of current perception
that guides action, we can act as it were
on the basis of that.
Did you have anything in mind or.
- [Lady] No, I didn't
have anything in mind,
but I was wondering,
so the direction you're
going is whether perception,
like what are the sources
for action guidingness?
And I was wondering about
the other direction,
such that could you just have perception
that isn't action guiding in some way,
or maybe I just dunno what it means
for something to be action
guiding in the relevant sense.
- Yeah, you you're right.
So that the kind of cases that someone
like Block might point
to where alleged cases,
where you have perception,
conscious perception,
but it's inaccessible
might count as cases where
there's those representations,
although they contribute to
what it's like to be you,
they're conscious are not
available for guiding actions.
I happen to think there
aren't any obvious such cases,
but that's not really
something I spoke in,
at all significantly about today.
- [Lady] Let's all right,
all right Paul, one last question.
(audience laughing)
- [Paul] Thanks.
I'll try to make it quick.
It's a methodological question.
Where are the qualitative data
sources on these conditions?
I thought it might be much
easier to adjudicate between
the golden braid view and Block's view
by just asking people who have blindsight,
what is your experience like rather
than putting them through
these complicated tests?
So where's the qualitative data here?
Is there some barrier to
interpreting qualitative data
that is not easy to see, or, yeah?
- Yeah, so that's a good question.
So I have looked very
hard to kind of assemble,
you know, subjective
reports of what it's like
to have blindsight in the literature.
And there are a bunch actually.
So the claim that GY makes on interview
that he's lost all vision to his right,
is undermined by his own reports
when he says things like,
you know, sometimes I can see orientation,
but then I lose all form or, you know,
as if there's some kind of failures of,
might describe it as like a
failure of binding of features
that you can see one type
of feature at a time.
He sometimes talks about how his vision
is a bit like what a normally sighted,
well, he uses the word
man, would experience
if they were looking out at a bright light
with their eyes closed and wave their hand
between the light and their
hand or something like that.
And he uses these lovely
phrases, like black on black,
like a mouse under a blanket.
So he has these evocative descriptions
of his own experience.
So there is qualitative work and it's also
this amazing paper though, that
I think really does it expose
what might be problematic
about some of this data.
So it's actually, it's a Hackman Lao paper
and it's a super interesting approach,
but I think at least the
philosophers in the room
will smile at it.
So what they decided they
needed to do with patient GY
who's really the most
extensively study paper,
was get GY to understand what quality are.
(audience laughing)
So they got these passages from, you know,
the Stanford Encyclopedia Philosophy
(audience laughing)
from like Jackson and Thai and
whoever and said, read this.
And he's a very dedicated subject
and reads his own literature.
So he read the philosophical literature
and do you have these?
And if you look at what he was given,
he was actually given these
kinds of the bright blue
of the Pacific Ocean that, you know,
the fresh smell of coffee in the morning,
kind of descriptions of quality.
And so what he said was, no, I don't.
Except on the very like high
contrast trials basically.
So I just think this
problem that criterion
is present in any kind
of subjective report.
It's just the psychophysical work,
uses it in a much narrow and
more controlled environment.
- [Lady] So let's thank (indistinct).
(audience applauding)